the military guides warns we need to
move fast the road to starry salty is
still dangerously exposed to enemy fire
and even though the russian military is
in retreat here
it is far from safe
all the villages have been battered
but so too have the kremlin's forces
remnants of tanks and armored vehicles
burned up on the side of the road
their bunkers are also smashed
and vehicles they'd used sprayed with
bullets
as we move further into the village what
we see is from another world
spindles of smoke pluming
apocalyptically
into the
sky
well the area we're in has been recently
liberated by ukrainian forces
but you can see the situation here is
extremely fluid
this area came under artillery fire
not long ago
and you can see these vehicles which
have been
completely destroyed
by russian forces
what happened to the civilians here is
beyond disturbing
this car packed with toys and baby
clothes as the family tried to escape
and in the midst of all this residents
are still trying to flee
this group only now able to move out
arena widowed by this wall
you know
rescue workers are still dashing through
the shifting front lines
these pictures filmed by the driver show
the danger they face as they try to
reach civilians
[Music]
the advances here are a sign of success
for ukrainian forces
but elsewhere russia continues to make
ground
both sides trading blows in a conflict
which is deepening every day
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine